pour lutter contre la maladie
d'alzheimer et les troubles apparentés
la science n'a pas encore trouvé de
remède miracle en revanche il existe une
prise en charge adaptée qui mise en
place au niveau national au sein des
établissements pour personnes âgées
dépendantes les étals il s'agit de pôles
d'activités et de soins adaptés dit pas
à aller pas des alizés à la saline les
bains le bazar est en place depuis cinq
ans pas assez un pôle d'activités et de
soins adaptés donc c'est pour les
personnes qui présentent une démence de
type alzheimer ou apparentée avec des
troubles du comportement modérés
on accueille à peu près 12 à 14
personnes par jour et on leur propose
des activités adaptées par rapport à
leurs troubles du comportement le bazar
fonctionne ici cinq jours par semaine
les 14 17 ans accueillis dans ce service
participe à des ateliers thérapeutiques
qui correspondent à leur savoir faire
aujourd'hui cet atelier cuisine je ne
souhaitais pas très connu ce village
rien de temps alors de mener 10 jours
aujourd'hui ça va être
ou poulet sauce aux huîtres avec brède
et en dessert une petite tarte aux
pommes je pouvais c'est elles qui font
tout ça oui ce matin enfin lièvre déjà
on a prévenu les résidants dont qu'on
allait faire plus une thérapeutique
aujourd'hui ce matin quand que je suis
arrivé donc je nous avons lillard cet
ensemble de
et des brèdes et aussi de du dessert est
en fait après nous allons commencer à
faire la cuisine des activités qui sont
proposées aux pas ah c'est pas des
activités occupationnelles donc c'est un
c'est vraiment un visée thérapeutique
donc c'est vraiment en lien avec leur
leurs troubles du comportement ça va de
la cuisine thérapeutique parce qu'il ya
des personnes dans notre base à qui on
est et cuisinières toute leur vie
un jardin aussi
donc voilà il ya beaucoup travaillé pour
les champs de canne ou
autre et du cou
rappel en travail de mémoire comme ça à
travers des ateliers mais aussi leurs
gestes du quotidien pour maintenir une
simon débute ses contours sont nettement
baissé la médication et détendue
comportement douter dans la proche des
professionnels les assistants de son
gérontologie qui sont formés à
accompagner des personnes vers plus
d'autonomie
vous croyez que l'on met des oignons
doit rajouter quelque chose à votre avis
comment fait on remet encore un petit
peu
il s'agit d'un travail d'équipé
tous les événements de la journée sont
détaillés et retransmis à l'équipe
accompagnantes pour assurer un suivi de
l'évolution des personnes s'est transmis
automatiquement à tous les collègues
pour monde peut avoir accès à ce matin
on a fait l'atelier cuisine
thérapeutique et en général on essaie de
garder les mêmes résidents sur
c'est à tenir comme ça tous les semaines
on s'aperçoit sur une évolution soit une
baisse des capacités des personnes dont
classe par exemple ce matin j'ai vu une
résidente qui
à l'habitude de couper les brèdes sans
difficulté je me suis aperçu que ce
matin c'était beaucoup plus compliqué
que d'habitude ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire
peut-être qu'aujourd'hui elle était à
laver moi envie peut-être qu'elle
n'était pas en forme je veux dire ça
veut rien dire pour l'instant
parce que si c'est bien perdurer dans le
temps là on pourra dire que le baiia une
baisse c'est qu'il ya quelque chose il
faut s'inquiéter ce qu'il ya quelque
chose qui ne va pas j'en prends tous les
résultats puis je fais des petits
diagramme comme ça donc ce qui me permet
de voir la fréquentation de la personne
dans le mois et aussi de voir si
l'atelier est adapté aux besoins de la
personne
ici on peut voir qu'en cuisine
thérapeutique ça marche plutôt font très
bien et on a une baisse d'un clip au
mois de novembre
en y réfléchissant avec l'équipe on
s'est rendu compte qu'en fait une dame
avec qui elle est très proche a été
hospitalisé à ce moment là et du coup on
voit que la participation au plaza était
un peu moins
j'ai besoin de beaucoup plus des
stimulations être en nombre réduit
permet d'être attentif à chacun monsieur
tondi est un ancien musicien il fredonne
un air
dans ce contexte il est possible d'y
porter attention et de parler de ce
qu'est pour lui la musique gratuit
j'ai arrêté il y arriver pourquoi vous
avez arrêté la ligue lundi par voie
comme ça d'un coup d'arrêt dans les gros
rouleurs empire démo technique côté je
peux maintenant j'arrive plus à part que
ça s'était toujours tout trop proche de
la musique où j'étais il ya des moments
qui passait par là
maintenant à moi maintenant je ne sais
pas pourquoi on reprendre sa saison
le pasa apporte un plus c'est un projet
que l'établissement souhaite développer
alzheimer 2008-2012 a permis d'équiper
un certain nombre d'établissements
notamment tous les établissements de la
fondation sont 28 ans équipé d'un mât
pas un
dans le cadre du plan 2009 2014 maladies
neurodégénératives il y a également donc
la poursuite de cette action donc il ya
vraiment la volonté au niveau des
pouvoirs publics de renforcer ses unités
là et de l'est de l'est pour suivre donc
la plupart des ehpad qui sont dotés
d'unités accueillant des personnes
atteintes de maladie d'alzheimer et des
démences apparentées apparentés vont
tête roues sont équipées de ne pas un à
l'heure actuelle c'est pas forcément le
cas en métropole mais à la réunion mais
quand même
on a cette chance là la journée est déjà
bien avancé après avoir déjeuné lors de
ce repas concocté par eux mêmes les
personnes accueillies en pas un peuvent
continuer des activités thérapeutiques
ou choisir de rejoindre les autres
résidents aujourd'hui il ya un goûter
d'anniversaire préparée par l'équipe
d'animation de l'établissement les
esprits soul bien reposé l envie de
participer est au rendez vous
et le soleil plus brûlants
qu'aujourd'hui